the reality about somebody who learns to
adopt an infinite mind seven like any
mindset it's it's a practice right like
mindfulness it's a practice somebody who
learns to adopt an infinite mindset
infinite minded folks they view let me
do it the other way around first finite
minded folks finite minded leaders are
afraid or threatened by uncertainty they
don't like surprises
and they like to exert a lot of control
over a situation which is why we tend to
see them operate in very short time
frames quarters and years because we
have a lot of control over how numbers
will work out over a quarter of a year
right five years ten years much more
difficult right and so in order to exert
control and avoid surprises we try and
maintain all control over the plan right
infinite minded view serve you
opportunity and surprises
they love uncertainty they think
uncertainty opens up the door to them
where finite minded leaders think
uncertainty is a horrible thing a thing
to avoid the thing that we're finite
minded leaders finds the feeling of
safety in the rules infinite minded
leaders find safety in relationships so
when you you can tell when your
organization is to finite minded when
you have too much bureaucracy because
bureaucrats like to enforce the rules
the way they're written right because
that's where they find safety as long as
I follow the rules my job is safe I
followed the rules right as opposed to
spending the time to build trust so
number one you the question is if you
have a very clear sense of just cause it
actually becomes obvious right it's not
actually a big decision in fact we call
it existential because to the person who
makes the Flex it's a death sentence
that they don't change but to the
outside world they think you're crazy
why would you trade the certainty of
this business for the uncertainty of
that business you've got a good thing
going one of the funny examples is
blockbuster blockbuster used to be the
800-pound gorilla they were the only
significant national player for video
and DVD rentals back in the day and this
little company showed up called Netflix
right and they had it they they had a
different business model it was
subscription
and you remember that they would send us
the DVDs right and streaming technology
wasn't good enough yet but we could see
it was coming eventually and the CEO of
Blockbuster went to the board because he
could see where the technology was going
right and he said to Blockbuster you
know we should probably look at the
subscription model and the board would
not allow him to embrace subscription
models because the company made 12% of
its revenues from late fees Blockbuster
does not exist anymore and Netflix has
completely reinvented television right
the point is they had no cause so they
couldn't see anything they could only
see a few freaks in front of them so if
you can only see a few frequent few feet
in front of you and those are the
discussions you're having at at the
table about what we're giving up and why
would we give up a certainty of this the
odds are you're looking down and you're
not looking up so you have to have that
just cause what are we working to
advance that's bigger than ourselves and
yes of course they were always finite
games within the infinite but there's a
context now why is it that Apple a
computer company invented iTunes and not
the music industry why is it that Amazon
invented itself and the e-reader the
Kindle and not the publishing industry
why is it that Netflix pioneered the
their business model and not the
television and movie industry it's
because those industries all of those
players were so busy competing against
each other and protecting the business
model they knew so well now they're
playing defense now they're forced to
change which is not existential
flexibility that's defense that's that's
gripping for your life right as opposed
to new companies that are burning in the
Arvin II aren't even in your industry
remember in the infinite game you don't
know all the players and sometimes the
players will be completely outside your
industry that will eat you lunch and put
you out of business you have to have
that just cause it becomes obvious
[Music]
[Music]